[Music]
hi everybody I'm Britney Lewis with
Forbes breaking news joining me now is
Ohio's Lieutenant Governor John housted
lieutenant governor thank you so much
for joining me absolutely glad to be
here right now we are backstage in
Cleveland at the under3 summit and
Cleveland is a city that has its hand in
producing the world's first billionaire
fund fact so tell us a little um best
known secret about Ohio something that
the world and the rest of the country
doesn't know well look we're the heart
of it all uh we make the things every
day that people need to live and Thrive
from the food you eat to the cars you
drive to the trucks that deliver to the
airplanes that fly and now the cloud
that connects us all and the chips
thanks to Intel's 20 billion chip
factory now the chips that process all
of our devices those things are made in
Ohio and made by great hardworking
people and uh that's a secret sauce to
our state I love that and Secret Sauce
is probably those hardworking people but
I want to know more about the
entrepreneurial Spirit specifically in
this state in your bio you wrote that
your mission is quote to make Ohio the
most Innovative entrepreneurial state in
the midwest so how are you doing that
well there's lots of things that that
are part of that first of all it's
Innovation are we doing the research and
development and making those Investments
so that new things can come to life and
we are particularly in the health care
space uh in the manufacturing space
those things are happening in our state
we're also creating a Better Business
environment Ohio is now consider
consistently ranked uh in the top 10 for
states to do business a and but that's
also entrepreneurship eliminating
friction all the things if there's
something that stands in the way from
you starting a business in Ohio I want
to know about it we're going to knock
down that barrier and and create an
easier path because we know starting a
business being an entrepreneur it's a
hard thing we want we want State the
state of Ohio to be the best partner
that we can be in helping people succeed
what are some of those new things
looking ahead that you're most excited
about that Ohio is making so let me tell
you one thing that we did uh we created
something called the Ohio IP promise and
and what happens is that we know that
there's so much intellectual property
that's developed on our college campuses
but it was always so hard to get it out
bureaucracy every everything that
happens on college campuses we created a
simple one-page form where it's a term
sheet that if you have IP you work at a
university uh you're affiliated with the
university you know what the terms are
you fill out one form and you can
commercialize it things that used to
take months or years to do can now be
done in days that's what we're talking
about it's taking Innovation to the
market faster than everybody else that's
what we're trying to do in our state as
I'm sure you know the economy continues
to be a top issue for Americans from
coast to coast Ohio included in that so
what do you think is needed in this
country to Spur entrepreneurship today
well right now in Ohio we have the
lowest unemployment rate and the most
jobs that we've had in our state's
history because we've created uh fewer
barriers to operation I think in the
country though that we have a lot of
States who are very high tax very high
regulation we have um a federal
government that that I think is holding
us back in some ways and so what we're
trying to do is is our state is to just
be that domestic supply chain for the
things that people need and that's why
our econom is doing well uh and America
just has to get back to the roof of what
America is about the American dream uh
and making it the place where people
want to invest where people want to live
where people can you know live that
version of what America is all about I
want to now turn to the under 30 Summit
where we're at today what's one piece of
advice you heard when you were under 30
that you still carry with
today well you know the things that
stick with me about that phase of my
life is uh you need to listen right but
you also have to believe in yourself I I
think that that's that's good advice for
someone over the age of 32 right uh but
but um but those are the things that I
remember you know having good mentors in
my life people who believed in me and
you have to believe in yourself uh and
what we need to do I think as an older
generation is to understand there's a
lot of good ideas out there that's where
you people who are under 30 are going to
see the world a little differently and
that's how great change comes about
that's how great Innovations come about
a Next Generation who sees the problem a
little differently through a different
lens that can bring their ideas forward
and they deserve to be at the table and
some of them like some of them here are
going to be the great Business Leaders
of our future in this country yeah right
outside the door there are about 5,000
of movers and shakers they're Millennial
gen Z what about them impresses you the
most what do you think of that group and
those young entrepreneurs in this
country I think they have I think they
have um
uh the right kind of values in their
entrepreneurial Endeavors I think more
of them are saying Hey I want to do
something that's about sustainability I
want to do something that's going to
make the world a better place I want to
do something that is virtuous and Noble
I see more of that in this generation of
entrepreneurs those in their 20s than
maybe we did in the past and uh and now
it's just about helping them figure out
how to make that into a money-making
Endeavor uh so that they can improve the
world and also so uh build a sustainable
business you're a leader in this great
state of Ohio what would be your one
piece of advice for these young
entrepreneurs out there that want to
lead in the workplace lead their
Community well look there's one key to
key to success is is just never give up
I mean you can never give up on your
dreams and it will be so hard being an
entrepreneur is one of the toughest
things to do it involves risks and uh
and UNC certainty but keep believing and
keep trying you'll figure it out to
those who are Relentless in their
pursuit of their dream those will be the
ones who succeed and I want to talk
about those risks every person has that
moment in their life that that decision
that changed everything what's that for
you when's the one time you bet on
yourself and it worked out well I think
I I was born with an unnatural or an
undeserved level of confidence uh in
myself in my belief it it is it is key
but but um I remember when I ran for
office the first time I mean you're
going out there you're putting your name
on the ballot you're asking the public
to make a judgment about you and once I
did it I said I was all in I went door
too for nine months knocking on doors
asking people to vote for me for the
state legislature uh and they did and uh
Now 23 years later I'm the lieutenant
governor of the state of Ohio I have the
opportunity to work on economic
development Workforce Development
Innovation uh I get to live uh I get to
live live every day the opport I get to
live with the opportunity to meet great
Ohioans every day but it all starts with
you got to believe in yourself and you
got to have a noble purpose and Mission
and then go out and sell people on it
and that's true whether you're in
politics or whether you're in business
and what's next for the lieutenant
governor well I'm laying the groundwork
to run for governor as our Governor Mike
dwine finishes his final term and we'll
uh we'll go out and continue to earn the
trust of the people of Ohio every day
but this is fun having entrepreneurs for
because because here's the bottom line
people of your state they want
prosperity and you got to create a great
business environment you got to support
entrepreneurs and you got to not do it
just for this generation but for the
next and these young people that are
here heck we're using this as an
opportunity to get them to stay in Ohio
invest in Ohio grow in Ohio uh because
we believe with a low cost of living and
a high quality of life and the fact that
we embrace them uh is is a great
commercial for the future of our state
and Forbes under 30 will be embracing
Ohio for the next few years lieutenant
governor thank you for joining me great
to be with
you